[Music]  maybe long as unless you  Beyonce and jay-z are already on the run  the couple was photographed riding a  motorcycle in Kingston Jamaica on  Tuesday that's J behind the wheel and B  holding on behind him it was so much fun  rockin pink boots and fishnet stockings  the two were reportedly shooting video  content that will be used during their  upcoming on the run to tour  after weeks of the Beehive buzzing  Beyonce officially announced the joint  tour on March 12 hosting a black and  white video with highlights from their  first on the run tour and these promo  pics between B and J are set to kick off  their tour on June 6th in the UK before  coming stateside on July 25th and on  Tuesday the a-list couple announced they  had added nine dates to the calendar  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]